[Music]
the Immaculate starwars the last Jedi
spread and vanity fair shot by renowned
photographer Annie Leibovitz made me
late to work today because I was weeping
in my car looking at it here's seven
things we learned about Episode eight
first of all Carrie Fisher and Mark
Hamill pictured on set together in
costume meaning Luke and Leia will
likely reunite on screen for the first
time in nearly 35 years the article says
filming at Pinewood Studios gave them a
chance to quote rekindle their benignly
rancorous brother-sister dynamic
according to Lucasfilm President
Kathleen Kennedy episode 9 would have
been a big film for Leia and while
they're still talks on how Fischer's
passing will be handled CGI is not an
option thank God quote we don't have any
intention of beginning a trend of
recreating actors who are gone but we
are at least getting our first look at
some new characters yes that's Laura
Dern pictured in purple as a prominent
officer in the resistance vice-admiral
hold oh sorry if I said that wrong and
Benicio del Toro as a shady unnamed
character who is called DJ by filmmakers
apparently we're going to find out why
and then there's ROS Rico played by
Kelly Marie Tran we learned at Star Wars
Celebration she has the biggest role of
the newcomers and will be spending a lot
of time with john boyega's Finn Finn
sees a lot of himself in her and she's
still trying to figure out her place you
know as Ryan said she's not a soldier
she's not a pilot so she's trying to
figure out what what what can she import
that's important to the good fight and
so they both have to figure that out
together one adventure Finn and Rose
will take is to the kanto bite Casino a
fancy new spot for the one-percenters of
the Star Wars universe but what the
internet is really wondering is that a
boffin and it both
I bring this information we've never
actually seen a boffin in the movies but
they do look something like this however
lucasfilm's Pablo Hidalgo straight-up
changed his Twitter handle - that's not
a bobbin we don't deserve you Pablo and
also boffins are described as about five
feet tall this dude is like pushing 900
feet yep I'm signing off talking about
bosses what was your biggest takeaway
you can at me here and of course may the
force be with you happy 40th
[Music]
you